en France on a toujours eu un truc
chelou avec notre façon de prendre la
température pendant des années il y
avait pas le choix le truc pour prendre
la température c'était le thermomètre
rectal alors attention me faites pas
dire ce que j'ai pas dit il y a aucun
problème à se mettre des trucs dans le
trou de mais bon disons que quand tu es
malade c'est pas forcément ta priorité
d'ailleurs quand je bosser à l'hôpital
les patients étrangers ça leur faait
toujours un petit peu bizarre parce que
c'est pas comme ça qu'on faisait chez
eux vous avez pas un thermomètre bucal
plutôt ah bah c'est les mêmes hein donc
vous pouvez y aller je les ai nettoyer
de toute façon ça va aller merci alors
maintenant ça y est c'est bon on a aussi
des thermomètres frontaux mais vous avez
vu à quoi il ressemble on est d'accord
tout le monde voit bien à quoi ça
ressemble non
bah sérieux c'est quoi notre problème
avec les thermomètres c'est pas grave
mais bon il y a quand même moyen de se
tromper
là je crois qu'il marche pas je ah mince
mais vous m'avez l'air un peu chaud
quand même j'ai regardé votre gorge on
sais jamais alors faites ah
ah